hello IMAX movie goes hey IMAX fans
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more when the
cameras first start rolling we just
think about one thing and one thing only
delivering on the audience experience
and that's why I mixed us IMAX up close
is the greatest thing ever because the
frame disappears to fill more of the
screen exclusively for IMAX theses see
more the character to see more of their
powers there's more storytelling the
look at a man in the waspy an IMAX is
incredible because you really get a
sense of how large chimein is
I'm gonna iMac that so rad [ __ ] having
the TV screen smashed into your face
I love watching films behind me it's my
fairy way to watch movies
it's the spectacle is the event
the colors they're so rich this film is
best appreciated in an IMAX screen you
just want to stand in front of it in all
[Music]
there's a filmmaker that's what you want
the audience to experience is just
storytelling freedom
the superheroes coming together sound
like the IMAX was the appropriate call
damn right
what is your time
I'm gonna show you something
[Music]
truth is I am Iron Man
you
[Music]